[Music]
Halla we took just lovers in my friends
this is cringing here welcome to my
first episode of refuting chess gambit
few days back some of our subscribers
had requests me to look at the current
trending net Monson gambit and guess
watch when I such on YouTube there are
dozens of videos recommending this line
including some big chest channels
but so far not a single channel comes to
rescue black site as in this world is
racist no just kidding
so rather than become a sheep worker I
decided to go against the wind and
making this video from the black
perspective the critical gambit position
arise after the following more ephone
'if i Knight to f3 Knight to c6 Bishop
to c4 and Knight to f6 we have two
Knights defense on the table and by far
the most aggressive response from the
white side is d4 so idea is when black
take this pawn white wants to quickly
castle on the Kings side and try to
launch an attack on the black King which
is time being stuck in the center now
against this black has two main choices
where Bishop to c5 leads to max lang as
well as scotch gambit territory however
the most frequent choice is Knight
captures efore where black is all set to
meet the main line move rook even
the recent trend focus on this very
tricky move Knight to c3 which is known
as neckman's and gambit and I must tell
you that if you first time say this move
you will be shocked as not only white at
this point to point down but he is
offering you a whole piece so what is
the big idea
now before I show you the antidote the
important point I like to mention at
this point is generally you need to
research or dig deep in order to defuse
any gambit but most amazing part about
Nachman Sinise all you need to know is
just one move yup you heard it right
just one move and followed up with a
universal plan which altogether sucks
all attacking power and completely
diffuse this gambit
although if you put this position in any
chess engine it will suggest that blacks
should either play the Moody capture c3
on night capture c3 my recommendation is
you play this golden moon Knight to d6
and after this all the gambit ideas are
completely neutralized
in order to understand why this is
strong moon let's roll back and consider
the scenario where black except the
speech sacrifice with D capture c3 well
after that here the fun begins for the Y
as he can continue with Bishop captures
f7 King takes f7 and now Queen to defy
not only getting one of the piece back
but after the obvious sequence let's say
K to eat root 2 even Bishop to e7 and
now rook captures efore
you can see the easiest plant from the
white side he wants to pressurize this
bishop on e7 and look at your pathetic
King which is stuck in the center where
none of your Queen side pieces are
participating
so the key moment is here imagine that
if you don't have night on e4 then this
variation is obviously not working so
what we are going to do is let's rewind
few moves and here instead of taking the
night we are going to play Knight to d6
well first thing first black is
attacking to peace so this pawn is
attacking the knight as well as this
Knight is attacking the bishop kindly
note that there is no Bishop captures f7
as this time are on we can capture back
with overnight
to be honest white doesn't have much
choice in this position and he can try
mainly three moves but as we will see in
this video against each of them black
get advantageous position in almost just
within the opening stage the first move
I want to consider is rook to even and
here comes the most important memory
marker in this line against all of this
white water what we want to do is
generally we want to play Bishop to e7
and then followed up quickly
castle on the Kings side which most of
the cases nullify all the white attack
let me show you what I mean here the
obvious moves Bishop to e7 and when
white continue with the only logical
reply Knight to d5
we will continue with this following
sequence Knight capture c4 Knight
captures c7 Knight captures a seven
Queen captures d4 and what we are going
to do yup we don't become greedy
we will castle and give our extra piece
back so that when white capture this
piece our big idea is first of all
evacuate this Queen from this diagonal
with defy doesn't matter wherever the
screen goes that say Queen 2 C 3 C 6
consolidating our extra pawn and once
black and managed to take this knight
and the bishop had some good squares I
think it is only white who is struggling
for any counter play in this opening
you
you
the second move I want to consider is
Queen 2 e 2 which is again goes into the
same territory do you remember of a
universal plant yup
Bishop to e7 and after night to defy the
same old story first capturing the
bishop queen capture Sifu and now castle
on the Kings side
after night captures d4 Knight captures
d4 and Queen captures D form
all we need to do is the claim in the
center and we can achieve this while
following forcing Mordor c6 Knight
captures e7 Queen captures e7 push up to
a four and now defy
white has clearly no justification for
loss of his bone
he can try some active moves such as
rook to even but after Bishop to e6
black is clearly in the driving seat
with that extra Center PO
last but not least what happens if you
open and continue with Bishop to g5 well
nothing special we will continue with
our universal plan Bishop to e7 Bishop
captures e7 nightcap to c7 and now again
White has two hanging pieces so white
responses force he has to play Queen
captures d4
but what it achieve is the same will
story nightcap to c4 queen capture
seafood and now yep
defy claiming in the center meanwhile
attacking the Queen and after few moves
let's say Queen to b4 castle rook to e1
we can safely put this night on a
wonderful square Knight to g6 followed
by consolidating of a center with c6 and
as you can see I have highlighted by the
arrows once we take out of a Queen and
Bishop I think dispositions only going
to favor the black cap
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this wonderful mini lecture on how
to meet the neck Munson gambit remember
at this point if you open and continue
with Knight to c3 do not grab that piece
but instead of that played this star
move Knight to d6 and after that no
matter however white riggles black can
look forward for the full point in
upcoming middle game with an extra pawn
advantage
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and I will meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care